hello from the future of koh samet in
busan i'm Touareg rifle researcher at
deep mind I'm here with Michael Redmond
9dan professional Michael what can you
tell us about the game I'm going to talk
about I moved it crotch I played also
I'm going to talk later about a move
that alphago played but the moves it
cage I played here invasion of the
33-point is a move that would sort of
unheard of at this stage of the game
until alphago played it about six months
again ago in a set of games that we're
calling the master game and usually it's
not played when white doesn't have
extensions toward the side but in this
case black invades the corner and
alphago made it work in a couple of the
games that it played in that sixty game
series and Kurt says actually being you
could say imitating death and with his
own interpretation of what alphago was
doing he is being using the same move
that alphago played so just looking at
this one move I can sort of see how kata
is trying to learn something from
alphago and use the tactics that alphago
was using Michael there was also this
move that alphago played can you tell us
about that well it's a very
strange-looking move in that from the
viewpoint of this enclosure here it
seems better for white to be closer to
the corner to protect the weakness there
so it looks really strange but actually
turned out to be a very effective move
and that it was setting up this peep
that came next and this people is
putting a lot of pressure on black here
where black has sort of captured these
four stones but this adds a lot of
potential to those four stones and it
also increases White's potential on this
part of the board so this move which we
didn't understand at the time was
actually setting up the peep and as the
game progress we gradually realized that
this is the point of the game were
actually wiped of control so this is an
example of how alphago can be strangely
effective in the way it chooses moves
that we don't expect fascinating and how
was this followed up then well after
black played here white peep once and
black played here to capture the four
stones and then white played here
and black extended and so black had this
weak group on the lower side and then
white played another fairly slow looking
move which cut black here and it didn't
actually threaten to save these stones
but it made a lot of extra potential for
white in the area and made white as a
result of that white was very strong in
this general area as we say thick and it
added some potential to attack these
stones and that ended with a good result
for white and so these two three moves
here which looked strange to us at first
we're actually probably the decisive
moves of the game or at least this part
of the game fascinating thank you